yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing I am cortex 408 cortex for
weights oh yeah he's very principled
going for the maroc see I also believe
that this is the best choice for white
against g6 yeah white has decent chances
for a small advantage I have some ideas
there in the maroc c4 black so I'm
trying to test them anyway it's not like
it's my own idea but it's something that
has been seen in games and something
that I also have played successfully
here in a recent game Bishop to f2 where
this is a small difference to Bishop e3
however for them plan that I'm going for
it doesn't make a difference the e6
Bishop e5 plan can be played regardless
the bishop is on f2 on e3 yeah he
regroups to eat to see - that's
interesting
makes it easier for white to play a for
some moment and f5 pawn takes rook takes
has now become impossible okay so he
might try to play for them for F form
Queen f6 as a potential move probably 92
happens yeah and he's got f4 lined up
them interesting
hmm yeah I wonder if I should just go
Queen to e7 no yeah that's the plan I
was thinking and this might be entirely
wrong that g5 is an idea looks loose
quite obviously but I'm not entirely
sure how bad it is
and maybe we should be three yeah who is
this guy by the way he go up yellow book
okay so covering this and f4 still feels
very dangerous no prepares it okay if I
go here and I mean f4 I think I can take
up GA this is fine I was more afraid of
f4 immediately head okay I don't have to
be right there okay whoop the 8 a 5 is
hanging hmm all kinds of looseness in my
position
generally speaking I'm not afraid of
this of the trade check something like
we need no I'm fine no I'm fine
everything's okay now
unless I'm overlooking something that
hits me quickly strategically speaking
this is okay now when he allows a trade
of one roof set is also very nice now I
go to e7 and should be completely okay
kick is rogue out yeah f5 is the way to
do something here or h5h form let's
prepare five yeah okay yes before it
doesn't doesn't scare so much I think
also ready to potentially go to hate I
had something with bishop a foreigner in
an earlier game and then there was an
exchange second d7 for the two pawns b5
Bishop back and night a4 also was
interesting for him okay so yeah I also
have this play against the c4 pawn I'm
not threatening this yet because of rube
t7 like Bishop takes Knight has Uxie for
up to 17 B 796 there are all kinds of
technical tricks going on oh okay that's
interesting
he wants to take on c6 and then check me
I guess on 95
also interesting J hmm is that a problem
I can do this now
there's no chick pawn takes roopd six
wins material rook to six King c4 bhakti
555 Knight b6 check
I guess 93 but then f 4 hits I know it's
a bit awkward now for white
take this check and I win a piece that's
pretty awkward I can take I'm not quite
sure I have to see where he go was there
night
I think I'll take I don't know okay push
him back first
94g for going to annoy him here with
tactics the whole time but my piece is
now coordinate quite well now at the
moment the Queen only six cops raided I
think black is quite okay okay so 95 97
so I can take this check check check
check
just take everything check maybe that
wasn't the cleanest way very likely
actually but it doesn't get easily get
there I asked to go back and now Knight
to a three would be good hmm that's a
good move check check how to do that
let's see that I get the Jeep on under
control but I don't see a way to win
here like time helps but say something
easy that I'm missing I don't know what
the engine says nothing there's no -
five or so that's what I'm trying to say
that it should be technically winning
it's quite clear there's no way to
promote
okay so let's fire the engine now yeah
it was interesting I think he had a
really good position here but then
played played the wrong plan with the
Bishop trade yeah g5 is certainly very
debatable move from him it's probably
bad
it's very ambitious but it's probably
bad yeah f6 or h6 so I think does this
look very logical 94 by the engine I
don't know I wouldn't have taken this
bishop defaults not a move that I would
have considered hmm why should I take
this I don't know I do this well the
engine likes the capture that looks
completely wrong why is that good
because ah because he's got f4 now
coming on okay that's really that's
logical in fact yeah the the computer
takes is sick so that the pressure on e4
gets relieved and King now king h1
now the dangle received an f4 okay okay
otherwise Knight X is six doesn't make
any sense to strengthen my scent or
something whatever it is that's to where
the engine is definitely correct down
okay look you won yeah and I think this
is wrong ninety-four seems better than
so after this year I'm fine when a
computer agrees that the only worry was
that I need some moves to to to
coordinate my position but it seems
there's nothing nothing wrong I felt
that this is better okay maybe b5 is
something that comes you that that
opponent didn't like in general I like
to trade one rook there and now I
control the deep
the default entry squares with the King
and can do things like f5 now can take
takes 95 for strong okay don't think
about that I know the engines evil goes
down
okay it has spotted this tactical idea I
don't know if I would have spotted that
kind of doubted especially as the point
isn't to push the pawn but to play this
move
preparing g4 that's a very sophisticated
stuff okay so this happened and again
you can take and check and here I'm
probably not so not in that bad shape 95
King is 6 J yeah and this is wrong damn
I suspected as much because now it's not
easy for right there this p5 idea is a
problem and what are you doing and this
is what he played if he goes here this
also be 5
he's got no check nothing I'm just
winning the pawn and here the same thing
applies yeah the key thing is that this
is a tactic check it's pretty free need
and this means he has no morally I
played this but then f1 and again if he
does that I have a check so this has to
be played and now I just won the
important pawn and before his weekend so
on him I probably as I'm miss plated
somewhere here King f5 here that's a
that's a good move that's a good move
directly that's very difficult now for
him but he probably has to go back this
is a very check check
very bad ending completely lost so he
would have maybe indeed have to go back
as the computer indicates and then
Knight f6 yeah this is great I'm your
two pawns up and have full control and I
didn't have control in game check was of
course better this is because of
material but you see it's not yeah it's
not all that clear so now I should win I
would see one a nice tactic F because
rupee to not see for there was a nice
chance okay at the end of the time got
to him okay guys thanks for watching